hello and welcome to this video playing
a k61 versa new accountant okay let's
see what he is having in store against
Petrov a Knight c3 you see if really
most of the time nowadays it's a very
simple way of playing for white young b6
v6 not it's a bit lame I would love to
play c6 in this position could put stuff
on light squares okay it's not at the
end of the world but still
we came not totally certain if I did
this correctly my experience with the
Petrov was still quite limited so I
sometimes stumble into things that on
closer inspection turned out to be not
good okay rook e8 he's not attacking
this
but depend on the deform
okay I'm not sure if I should go to 85
him he wasn't yet attacking it but I was
thinking c6 could be an eidm to check
the deep horn and I know he is pushing
he just pushes it
take it Queen a six
see 696 so that's not not a threat yet I
have to get rid of the background
problem it's not really possible to play
with such a weak background the whole
time
okay so here if I take on c5 is going to
move the Queen somewhere to a6
[Music]
can also take here don't think it's bad
but if I call wait if I go Knight to d7
what is this move it cannot take on c7
as the Queen is hanging now we're
looking at trickier c6 maybe and then
take on c7 I even that is not clear but
yeah that's probably what is going to do
yeah C 6 C 6 take on c7 have $95 96 or
something along these lines and
threatening Knight takes e5 so I don't
really see ya okay c6
f95 a2 is hanging that can be can be
important not threatening to take on d6
rook-a for it's not a threat but close
look a for Queen d2 were still still are
possible
didn't don't have much time
takes takes and threatening on each 195
I tricked me not not necessary at all to
use this game I think white white was
just overextended nothing more nothing
less
I should never lose it it was badly
played wide it's just all way extended
here this is this is totally fine for me
I don't believe it
okay so c5 my engine thinks white is
fine and maybe it works like technically
but it felt overextended to me so we
take take age 6 of d6 yes he six was
what I was thinking he didn't play it
and white is better after Intel I mean
it did also just just look better than
what he did but still I felt like I
should be may be able to pick this out
but doesn't look like it
yeah doesn't look like a now a c6 I mean
here must be totally fine I don't
believe it one bit b5 because this is
now more richness
I got Church that's fine
yeah Bishop f4 wasn't good Jam
so c5 is the move again I didn't have
anything substantial I wasn't and I
wasn't believing that I was winning or
anything no that that's not the case but
I felt I'm sure we should be seven I can
just do this and Bishop evade just
continues from there not good
yeah anyway I think a good game by my
opponent I wonder I wonder I mean this
looks extremely feeble no III in this
position I am second I can Castle first
maybe this is actually a little bit more
precise you know I don't really hate to
play b6 but if I am able to avoid it I
would prefer the further had castles if
i delay this whole thing I'm ready to
play 97 yeah that would be nicer to do
we had to put this here and don't play
b6 yeah that's not much at all I mean
here this is not an issue but I felt I
should be having less less problems to
coordinate yeah Bishop f6 seems wasn't
best yeah again I'm rather new to this
opening after so Blaine learned
understand it better
thanks a lot for watching